19 states have suceeded the United
States Army ramps up activity the White
House issued warnings to the Western
forces as well as the Florida Alliance
the three term president assures the
uprising will be dealt with swiftly let
me know if you want to try anything on
are you guys aware there's like a pretty
huge civil war going on all across
America we just try to stay out with
what we see on the news seems like it's
for the
[Music]
[Applause]
best citizen of America the so-called
Western forces of Texas and
California have suffered a very great
defeat at the hands of the United States
military Mr President do you regret the
use of air strikes against American
citizens we're moving to DC today we
need to go down there they shoot
journalists alls side in the capital
every Instinct in he says this this is
death
blood every time I survived the war zone
I thought I was sending a warning home
don't do
this but here we are there's some kind
of misunderstanding
here we American
okay okay what kind of American are
you you don't
know
the Western forces will reach the White
House on July 4th oh my god get in the
car get in the
car move move
Mo you're going to hang back I'm not
hanging back one
nation under
God
indivisible with
liberty and justice for home go go go go
go God Bless
[Applause]
[Music]
America